[音楽]
4日
voodoo ん
[拍手]
いや皆さんがね今抱いてるねめっちゃ
新しいなやつ来たなっていう違和感おい
正解なんですよね
今日のだらしい nasa の話をしに
行きました
貯木ハメなやつで今日もあの1時間遅れて
ここに来ちゃったんですけど
でしかも美汐ライブお友達にとってもらっ
てて今日かぶってて朝奥さんにここいくん
かメッシュリボンかどっちかハッキリ生て
怒られてここに来たんですけどそんな奴な
んですよねえ
まあ見てもらうと分かるんだけどね僕のか
メール9万5000県溜まってるんです
けど10万件に行かないようにがんばる
っていうのは僕の今は努力していることで
子供服はそうなんですなかなか時間も守ら
れへんし頑張ってはいるんですよ
小学校の時言うじゃないですか
授業中走り回ってるやつあれ僕です
で先生に怒られてなかなか学校行くのも嫌
でちゃんとしようちゃんと仕事でなかなか
できなかったんですよね
でねーなんか
をしようと思ってそのまま大人になって今
ここにいるんですけど
ほんとねそういう奴がですよ
今日皆さんあの18分間これから僕が皆
さんに合わせるんじゃって皆さんが僕に
18分か合わしてエンパシーを送って
ください
そう
白糸200万あるんですよ
多分をはないかなと思ってるんであの
すごい勢いで行くんでついてください
でこんな僕にも得意なことが実はあって
こんな感じです僕の仕事
カオスを作るのがすごく大好きですね子供
であったりおじいちゃんばあちゃんであっ
たり外国人だったしあったりいろんな人が
いてもなんかごちゃごちゃ入れんけどなん
か楽しい時間をつくるっていうのがすごく
得意です例えば6趣味がサウナなんです
けど
10塗装なかったですよと謙虚にサード
できるけど若者で集まったこういう絵に
なりますよねでもねここにね子供混ぜたり
とかね
大丈夫このおばあちゃんだと思う大丈夫
行っちゃうんですよね
めちゃくちゃとと思ってるでしょこういう
の作るの大好きなんですよ
同じ空間ですよ車椅子のおじいちゃんも
一緒にタンス見ちゃうんですよ
整ってますよね
こういう時間を作るということだけはなん
かできるなぁと思って
でねー
今日でたをはないで先に結論を言っておき
ます
人生において解決できる問題よりも解決
できない問題のが多いと思っていてどうに
もならないことをどうでもええことにと
思ってすごい大事なことだと思ってて
僕このカオスな環境中でそんなことない
学びましたなので今日の結論これですあと
は18分間おしゃべります
100枚組んで皆さんを付け下さい
いきなりクイズなんですけど違和感を探せ
骨写真ですよね加温機の横に外国人いて
なんか親やてねこれ大丈夫かあって違和感
はリバリアと思うんですけど皆さんこの
写真がへ10分後
違和感なくなるっていうマジックを今から
離しますだからこの写真木後出てくるに
覚えてくださいなんかちょっと行為は感じ
ですがい大丈夫みたいな
神戸市長田区の生まれで阪神大震災の被害
がすごく後です
当時小学校3年生でした
で
うん
ほんと友達はなくなったし
町は焼けちゃって何もなくなったんですよ
ねでもその時助けられてってた人には共通
点があってどういうことかっていうと日常
のコミュニティを持ってるします
なるほどなって本当に大変な時って顔の
見える関係ってすごい大事なんやというの
子供中に覚えてましたなので今ハード面を
作るっていうよりもどちらかというとそう
とつまり暮らしであったりコミュニティを
つくるというのはすごい大事だなと思い
ながら仕事をしています
これ当時の僕の暮らしなんですけど社宅に
住んでて
ブラジル人中4人と一緒につまされてまし
たん
めちゃくちゃですよ言葉も分からないし
文化も違うとかなりストレスを抱えながら
でも折り合い好きだからなんとかせなあか
んなっていう感じでもうどうでもええわ
って思えるようになってから暮らせるよう
になりました
まあそんなことも事態だったんですけど
そんな僕が音になったらこうなんですよね
シェアハウスを作ると
はい子ちゃまぜです
子供もいますしえおじいちゃんばあちゃん
主外国人も良いしここ多いときに集200
in いろんな人が来るリビングはず
そんなリビングがあるシェアハウスをやっ
ています
なぜやっているかと言うとあの社会のため
手入れも
本当に行きづらかった自分
ももいわゆるた道ですよね
もうしんどかったんですよ
で
まあなんとか男になることになる仕事をし
てで結婚したんすね奥さんはあの僕と真逆
の性質
1点集中型の絵描きなんですけど絵を
書き出すと他のことが見えなくなると家事
もままならないですよねそんな二人が結婚
して子供が産まれたんですよね
おっとったと思う
頼むから俺22なよと思ったら僕にちゃっ
たじゃ特性がエリートでめちゃくちゃ元気
なんです保育園からプラスワンで先生を
突き上げるみたいな
今とそういう荒野+で学校行ってなかった
僕が
学校行くかなぁーとかどうしようかなとか
めちゃくちゃ侵犯し出させ
心配して的に同時期何が起こったかという
とおじいちゃんおばあちゃんの介護が
始まった2人とも認知症でどうしようと
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんの介護自分の
仕事を子育てどれをセーブしたらいいん
やろうという
なんでセーブ生のわかんないと思います
なんでオレが諦めな感じでみんなのほかも
は不貫き通したどうなるのかなって作った
のがここです僕もいますクラッシュ家なん
ですけどここには赤ちゃんからおじい
ちゃんおばあちゃんまでいろんな人が
集まっています
こんな暮らしを作りました
大事にしてることは日常の登場人物を
増やすこの外でいろんな人が来るんで何を
やってあげたら良いか分からないですねで
も日常に関わる人を増やしてなんかこう
楽しいことが見つかったらいいなとか良い
台があったらいいなあということを意識し
ながら暮らしています
これ昼は生活なんですけどあの家の子供小
学校1年生の時に赤ちゃんいっぱい包んで
魅力も上げる子を持つも変えるっていう
なんか保育士スキルが付いてしまって
同時によりまで切ると3人やから良い
らしいですけど
眠いその時おばあちゃんのね食事介助をし
だしてませんこれ難しいですよこのバッタ
しゃべれないですよね
非言語のコミュニケーションがいるかなり
高エンパシーを使わないとなかなかでき
ないません
でも出来てるからなんで生きてんのって
聞いたら赤ちゃんと一緒に合う
なるほどなってもこれ本誌やなと思っ
こんな学びを感じながら暮らします
ここにはいろんな人が集まっていますもう
この写真も全員たになんですよね
家族もちろん家族大事ですけど他人の価値
を見直すことによって人間って暮らし
やすいんじゃないのかなっていうのを感じ
ながらそこを大事にしながら
うちのおばあちゃん
近くのた林に囲まれながら生活をしてい
ました
ねうちの娘元気過ぎて
あのなんか差し上げたになったら神体のが
高かったんですねだから体操教室入れて
あげようと
そしたら1日的になりました
なぜかというと1日目でこいつをぶっ壊し
てしまう
なんか可哀想だなぁと思ってその能力
生かしたいなとか言い張ったら誰も文句
いわやる
やってみた際大暴れすればするほどみんな
めちゃくちゃ喜んでくれるん
もうこれはもうキラーコンテンツスシロー
ちなみにこれを抑えているのは要介護人の
入居者のおじいちゃんです
これも年日常の中でやるから喜んで
もらえるぞ
もう自分の大暴れを発揮しながら
うちのおばあちゃんなんですけどここでは
命の終わりが日常の中にありますうちの
ばあちゃんもあと1か月で来れなくなる
んですけど
それを見てはこれね最後すごく良かった
ですからなんか微笑ましいでしょう知って
ねこの中では強いものじゃないですよなん
か日常の中にある
じゃあ自分の最後得意分野見てほしいよ
ねーっ
これはなくなる一色あんまりおばあちゃん
に披露できた体操教室です
ね亡くなった後もね
怖いとか悲しいよりもありがとうという
気持ちが先行するんですね
もうね棺桶までみんなで作って飾り付けも
みんなであるんですよそうやって送られて
いくっていうカオスなバーを作っています
これもお葬式ですよ
暗くなり性が高いですよね
影響を100枚あるんで僕を持っている
こと喋ってるだけ皆さんの中で消化して
ください
これは違うのはおばあちゃん喜んでるけど
こうやってを止めたぞ
和え物これも今日は君じゃなきゃ目ます
これもらい見て口面白いですけど今日も
気分じゃない止めます
これできますか
このおじいちゃんお酒が大好きなおじい
ちゃんでうちに入居することになったん
ですけどさて飲みすぎて身体壊しちゃせん
ねウチに来るときにまひがあってほとんど
動かなかったんですよ
どんなリハビリをしたらいいですかって
聞いたら嫌なんで俺が姉見せないかなと今
まで頑張ってきた
ほかって生まれたそれじゃあ何がしたい
ですかっていうのは酒飲みたいわかりまし
ただそうでいきましょうかと
いきましょうかと
一人のでもつまらんからみんなで飲む場を
提供した常飲み会の場をわっかり
リハビリをせずにオシャレ
はぁ
踊っちゃって作っています
どんなリハビリしたんやっていっ
もみんなびっくりしですがお医者さんが
一番びっくりです元気に元気になってね
車椅子の使い方間違ってるんでも
盛り上げ隊も飲み会の盛り上げたいみたい
になっちゃいました
ねこれはピースしてますよねこれこの
ピース多分皆さんができないですなぜなら
まああなたの余命は2ヶ月ですと言われた
瞬間の写真がする笑っていますよ
でも病院にいるよりも住み慣れた場所で
また最後みんなと楽しく過ごせるから俺は
嬉しいんだとそうですかじゃあそれでいき
ましょう
ね色んな人がねお酒飲みに来るんですよね
登場人物たちがう
これがこのおじいちゃんの予定でした
でね最後にキャバレーをみんなで行きた
いって言うじゃウイダーシャツキャバで
再現しよう生ということでこれは家の
リビングでドンペリ開けています
めちゃくちゃのコンディション
ポールダンサーも読んじゃってみんなで
どんどん上げます
本番いなくなるあーこの亡くなる1週間前
です
他のおじいちゃんたちもめちゃくちゃ喜ん
でくれておばあちゃんもマスクして
ちゃんと打っ楽しんでいます
雑賀奥さんと乾杯してね
これなくなる1日前の薄いかわいいです
かっこよく送っているとじゃあやりました
ぞ
これが正しいのか正しくなるか分からない
でもそのおじいちゃんが元いたじゃない
そうしようかっこいい国だというなんか
その子調印にこの生活と相手が
めちゃめちゃ嬉しかったらしくてこの写真
貼ってくれって言うがあったら入りました
俺みたいなやつ合唱にあるなんてみたいな
いろんなとうとう人物だったりいろんな
出会いがあるんですねそんな思いでの話を
しながらかっこよく
ひたすらかっこよくこのおじいちゃんを
送ることができました
僕思うよ日本の社会ですごく厳しくないか
なんかミスしたらすぐ責められすぐ揚げ足
とってそれでね多分結局ね人に厳しいのは
その人とまた会えると思ってるからさ今日
もしかしたらこれが最後かもしれないと
思ったらそんなことにならないですよって
いうのを僕はこの人から貰いました
すごく合った方を加えるですね
でここで大事にしているのは男子なさあで
自在するただしなさってす開くなのかと
思っていて
なんかねえ
減ってそんなにきっちりしないでしょなん
かただしな差があるといろんなことが許さ
れるかなと人の弱さであったりとか
生きづらさそれもだらしなさが一つと
捉えると話しあさって結構大事なんちゃう
かな
そのだらしなさを愛してみるってすごく
大事だと思ってて愛せるか木でいいんです
よ
よく日本人は
自分に厳しく人に優しくっていうけど
それって一部の成功しか僕は無理なん
ちゃうかなと思っていて
僕みたいな弱い人間は自分に甘く
そしてやっと人に優しく自分にめっちゃ学
っていうことですね僕の中であるいろんな
トラブル起こりますでもみな歌手ん以上の
トラブルないでしょ
jica にこう楽しく乗り切るかって
いうのはすごく大事て例えばクラスターを
着たんスね家
フィリシアを見てるからじゃあこれと
面白く切り抜けるのかと
このおばあちゃん部屋によってください
って守ってくれないんだよね忘れちゃうん
で
このマム少女妖精です
そんな人を押し込めておくことはでき
なかったんですよねじゃあもう最強になっ
てもらう
無敵です
むてけいすだれ親父かけない
頭の使い方なんですよね
このばあちゃんこの日誕生日でした本来で
あれば米クラスターから誕生日来年でお
願いしますって僕らに言っても ok だ
けどこのおばあちゃんは3カ月後半年後
生きてるかどうかわかんないですよ
そこに対してじゃあ今成するから誕生日
ようなかや
つまり楽しいことを楽しむというのは誰で
もできるでも難しいこととかどうしょうも
ないことを楽しむっていうのはすごく想像
力がいる前向きな姿勢が入るとか思ってい
てそんなことをこの場で大事にしながら
学びました
きましたよはじめの写真が
ちょっとこの写真の右肩が皆さん変わり
ませんか
なんかこうを取ってるけどもしかしたら
いろんなストーリーがこの中にあるんじゃ
ないのかな
10分あればね捉え方ってちょっと変わる
んですよ初めて明らかに変わってるはず
です
踊ってますよ
残りは何だか私なんて温かい物語組んだ
からみんな笑ってるんですよ
えっ
はぁ
ちなみに彼を気に入ったこのバージョン
です人生最後の誕生日を迎えると思って
なかったとでも迎えたんですよ
最後やから悲しいじゃないんですよね
代頃から一緒に立ち会えてよかったって
いうのがぼく自然やと思うぜ
で今日僕実はあの一切緊張してなくて
当たり前なさなぜならば
あの2プレゼンって皆さんのために話すか
もしれないけど僕はの過去の自分のために
今話ですよね
やっぱりこう行きづらかったしちゃんとせ
なあかなと思ったしすごいを自分の力で
解決できないトラブルぬ
ね生まれたきゃってほしいのかなと思った
んですけど
なんかその時に何だろう
ほど保証もなかったなというふうにすごい
人に救われたなと思ってて
そんな自分に対してきお話ししてるんで皆
さんに対し話してるつもり全くないね no
緊張ます
この場所にはいろんな違和感があります足
の動かないおばあちゃん目の見えない人を
しゃべれない人
ちょっと心が弱い人走り回っていることも
お酒飲んでる人外国人いろんな人がいます
けどなマイノリティがいますでも一個一個
の問題を解決しようするとすごいしんどい
かもしれないけどもう自分の中の非常に
増やすことによってどうでも良くなると
いうかあの人が禁止いることってそんな
大したことか本人が一番見えないぜ
僕は今亀津以上個サルとどうでもよくなる
と言ってるんだけどどうでも良くなるって
いうのは勝ちだと思っています
そして違和感を感じたら
背景を想像してください例えばこの写真赤
ワイン
葬儀のところでこの大丈夫かじゃなくて
もしかしてこの赤ワインってどういうもの
が大会が大好きだったのかなとかこれもあ
じゃあ何なんやろこんな日常もしかして
あったのかもしれない
その後ろにある廃棄を創造するってすごく
あた外交やと思っています
もししんどい方いたら皆さんの日常のなか
に普段はない登場人物を増やしてみて
ください
そしてそこにあるだらしなさというのを
愛してみるということをしてみてください
コツは自分に甘く人にやさしく
そしてそれを面白がってみるっていう姿勢
が
なんかこう
色んな役づらさとか難しい問題がある時で
もなんか前抜きに行き得るコツなのかなと
思っていますはい
ねぇ
今日僕がしてる話って別に世界を変える
開いている dear でもないしなんか
すごい9 ea ページ部の話ではない
です
でも皆さんであったりとかまぁ本当に過去
の自分に入ってますけどめちゃくちゃ
しんどい時にこの考えがちょっとでも
逃げ場になればいいなと思っていて
僕と同じく
何か解決できない問題に悩んでいる人か
もし今いたら
この話を聞いてちょっとでも楽になって
くれたらいいなーっ
この混沌とした環境って
ある時はセーフティに入ってもやるし
ある時は自分がどうでもいいやと思った
瞬間に
他の人を見ながら自分ってもしかしたら
こう行きたいかなって前に進んば意味が
あると思ってて
なので皆さんの日常2位は顔出して言って
その背景を想像して
だらしなさを愛してみるんそんなことが
過去の自分に伝わればいいなと思って今日
話をしています
本当に僕が信頼的に
周りにいてくださった方々
登場人物になってくださった方々本当に
ありがとうございましたそれだけを言い
たくて来たのですいません皆さんためじゃ
ないです
8関わってくださる方本当にありがとう
ございました
[拍手]